I had a father that was touched by stroke...
...and sick for seven years.
We were able to get the very best in terms of health care...
...because we were able to afford it.
It would have bankrupted any average family in this nation.
Any average family that is represented in this hall...
...this afternoon, and the millions of people that you represent all over this nation of ours.
I had a son that was touched by cancer.
Extraordinary health bills...
...that we were able to afford, and we received the very best.
It would have obliterated and wiped out the savings of any family, mortgaged their savings...
...and mortgaged the education of their children into the future.
Seven months in the hospital I was with a broken back...
...and received the very best of health care.
I've been able to receive it for myself and for my family...
...just like all of us around the tip of the iceberg.
Way up high in the health care services.
We've got the very best, all of us at the tip of the iceberg.
But I want every delegate at this convention to understand...
...that as long as I'm a vote...
...and as long as I have a voice in the United States Senate...
...it's going to be for that Democratic platform plank...
that provides decent quality health care,...
...north and south, east and west for all Americans, as a matter of right and not a privilege.